who will help people walk through this
process
so we're going to make sure that
the people who didn't have the dollars
and had to stretch
and those who haven't been able to have
burials because some people have
are still staying laying in funeral
homes and elsewhere without burials get
those dollars
and the second thing we're going to do
this law applied for all of 2019
from i believe it is march to the end of
2019
we're going to make sure we renew this
in the new bill we're working on that
already
the arp bill that president biden
proposed
so it will apply for all of this year
till the covet crisis
ends this is only a fair and humane
thing to do
this is the kind of thing our country
has done before
and we're glad that we were able to be
pro provide this very very needed relief
and we will keep fighting on this issue
and many other issues
to make sure that the people of new york
and of the country
particularly those who don't have the
means to
keep going on their own during covid get
the help they need
with that let me call on the
congresswoman
thank you so much senator schumer and
thank you to our community leaders that
we have here in corona thank you luis
thank you
um here at latina natalia natalia thank
you
natalia and thank you of course to syeda
dunstan
at elmpore who really just helped kicked
up
kick off this um this effort in a very
major way you know about
a year ago um new york city became the
epicenter of the epicenter and right
here
in corona queens we had one of the most
heavily impacted zip codes
in the united states of america when it
came to covid cases
this is when kovitt had just hit new
york city
and we were just trying to figure out
what exactly was happening
and how the pandemic was hitting the
united states
and it was in that moment that we
started to hear from community leaders
right here in new york 14 and in corona
and around east elmhurst that this
pandemic was not hitting
all of us equally it was hitting
black families hard it was hitting front
line workers hard it was hitting
immigrant families extremely hard
working class
families and it was disproportionately
impacting
along lines of race and along lines of
class
and so what we saw was that the pandemic
while we were while it was should i wait
on this
okay
in this build to make sure the trains
keep running yes that too
and so what we saw was that um while
this pandemic was hitting
all of us um and while we were all in
the same storm we weren't all in the
same boat
and some of us were riding very choppy
waters and what that means was
that the communities that were being
hardest hit
were having higher levels of mortality
and what that means is that when black
brown and working-class families are
getting hit
disproportionately hard with cases it
means that they're also
losing more people with higher levels of
mortality
and you know i lost my dad when i was
about 18 years old
and the funeral expenses haunted and
followed
my family along with many other families
in a similar
position for years
when you suddenly lose a loved one
you're talking about an expense of
four five seven ten thousand dollars and
then during covid
with overrun uh funeral facilities etc
families also are being are having to
deal with having to pay for the storage
of the bodies of their own loved ones
this is wrong and so i'm i'm thrilled to
be able to um
to have such strong and powerful
community leaders here
to alert us to this as soon as
everything started to hit
um syeda dunstan just called me up right
away
and she said this is going to be a
problem this was probably the same week
that everything shut down
and we got to work right away and so we
brought this up i brought it up
uh and and conference with senator
schumer and we made it a priority for
our state and for our country
and so once again if you are a family
that lost a loved one
please make sure that you start to
document
and please make sure that you start to
collect all documentation of the costs
of burying a loved one make sure that
you start to assemble this
get your death certificate so that we
can make sure that we can reimburse the
costs
to your family up to seven thousand
dollars we have two billion dollars
allocated
and this is uh reimbursable and
retroactive
back to march 2021 at the beginning of
the pandemic so
uh with that i just want to thank each
and every one of you and thank
uh our our community leaders and i want
to i'm just
so proud to introduce aida dunstan of
elmcore
um who just let off this effort is just
a phenomenal community leader
and you know without without her we
wouldn't really be here today so
thank you so much
good morning everyone i want to thank
the congresswoman
on a very personal level because many
people hear when you're saying things
but not everyone listens
and so i want to thank the congresswoman
for listening to me that day and
listening to our community
and senator schumer for following up on
that it's really important that people
understand what it means to be the one
to make the call
it wasn't because of me it was very
early on as
the congresswoman said it was early
because it was before the statistics
were out
it was before anyone was saying black
and brown people were dying at higher
rates
but we knew it because as grassroots
organizations like both as latina
and natalie we know we don't have to
wait for the data
because our people are calling us the
phones are off the hook we're
literally listening to people say my
family's dying
i had a participant who lost four family
members in one week
and this was before april so for us
we lost our first staff person here in
corona
on march 23rd we didn't need to wait for
data
if you're not listening to community
organizers
if you're not listening to those who
have their boots on the ground we will
always
miss it the concern for me at the time
when we were talking
was that i remembered the hiv epidemic
when people would leave their family
members
literally leave their family members at
hospitals because they couldn't afford
to bury them
and so i knew this was going to be a
problem because if this many people are
dying
no one is prepared for that no family is
prepared for that
there's not enough life insurance for
that this was a disaster
this was a disaster and fema stepped up
in the way
only because there was pressure and so i
just want to make sure that the
community knows
that as long as you speak someone will
listen and we are lucky to have a
congresswoman and a senator in our
district
who will but we have to be the ones to
start the conversation
we're responsible for our community
thank you
and now we have some great leaders in
new york
and one of them who looks out for this
issue and so many others
is frankie moran to the head of the
hispanic federation
thank you thank you everybody uh thank
you
majority leader schumer for his
leadership also a great champion of
our community alexander
latinas and all my colleagues here i
wish we were not
we didn't need to be here today but as
it has been said before
very early on after so many years of a
toxic narrative about around our
community by the past administration we
knew that people
were going to stay in their homes
because they were afraid
they were afraid to look for services
they were afraid people were
dying in their apartments and people
asked me why
and i said our community had no other
choice they had to go to work
for us to stay home they have to get
sick for us to stay healthy
and they have to die for us to live for
you and i to live
and right now we have an opportunity to
correct
a little bit of that pain in our
community
we need to make sure that everybody in
our communities of color
know about this incredible opportunity
that
it will somehow relieve them from the
enormous pain that they have already
already suffered
there are too many kids that have lost
parents caregivers
grandparents this is a way to start
correcting the wrong
the past administration didn't care
about us but now we have
a leadership that really care about us
and communities of colors
and i want to thank again majority
leader schumer
and alexander classic cortez congressman
for being the champions of our community
and helping us correct a little bit of
the pain that we have been suffering
thank you frankie frankie is one of our
great
latino advocates here in new york and
now we have
natalie rubio and she is one of the
leaders of voces
latina
hi everyone first of all thank you very
much for hispanic federation for always
being here for our community senator
schumer and congresswoman
um ocasio thank you uh for all the work
that we've been able to do together
i'm natalie rubio toriel i'm executive
director of voces latinas we are in
jackson heights on 83rd street
we're an hiv and violence prevention
agency
in the last year we have
we have basically expanded our mission
because of covid in our community
it's hit us so hard that our staff our
families our clients
have we're hospitalized and we've
unfortunately lost planes as well and
family members
i just want to say this is something
that we've been waiting for so thank you
so much for your fight thank you so much
for always
being the voice of our community and i
say that being the voice because you
look around
first of all i thank you for bringing
the press conference to
the very community that it's affecting
but i also say being the voice because
there's so many people that we see
that are not around here at bosses
latinas we go
and i know and i know we work together
closely with syeda
we go to the subpopulations that you
normally do not see that will not be
knocking on our doors looking for help
because of the fear of immigration
so we go to them and we're talking to
them as well and they're
they're living a reality that not many
people know and it would be great to be
able to bring these resources to them
so that people start really realizing
what else
who else lives in these communities
that's suffering struggling
freezing at night not losing jobs losing
families but also losing housing
our people are freezing our people are
out of work
they're they're they're under bridges i
mean the homelessness has just
tremendously increased in this area
so i cannot i cannot thank you enough
for fighting the fight being there and
being in always having our undocumented
folks in mind also because they are the
ones that are in the shadows are
considered invisible
but need this very resource at the
beginning beginning of the pandemic we
received many phone calls
we did distribute cash funds to be able
to provide funeral expenses
and be able to uh give our community
a burial with dignity something that
everybody deserves
so again thank you so much for your work
you have us
in your side in your corner thank you so
much thank you for always
including us most of latinas in the
fight in the in the in the work
so i want to um just say again we're
here thank you very much for all your
support and help
and please do not forget our community
thank you very much
okay questions on this stuff on this
topic
uh it is january 1st 2020
sorry yes uh it's january 1st 2020 until
december 31st 2020 and they're both
fighting for it to become
proactive going forward in the new bill
we're trying to get it to go from
january 1st
2021 until the crisis is over however
long that is
sorry i apologize but um
you might have to submit
yes of course you know i think um and
it's completely understandable why
they're that why there's that fear there
especially over the last four years of
targeting of our
uh immigrant families but i think
right now our families especially under
a biden administration a democratic
senate and a democratic house
that is prioritizing immigrant rights
including those of the undocumented
to not have fear and to not allow that
fear to further marginalize our
communities
she
um
you have to show that you couldn't be
able to afford a funeral
some people you know seven thousand
dollars even if you had a good
job but then lost your job isn't
available when you have to feed your
family pay the rent etc
and we are going to work congresswoman
and i are going to be working with fema
and they've been very cooperative
in making these regulations very
friendly to people
including for the undocumented
any others on this subject
okay you can stay here if you want and
hear what i have to say on immigration i
mean on
impeachment okay no it's good news
actually
your managers got what they wanted i'll
trade you
okay all right on impeachment
let me just
okay so let me just say this um
we are finalizing a resolution that's
been agreed to
by all parties the house managers
the former president's council leader
mcconnell and i
that will ensure a fair honest
bipartisan senate impeachment trial of
donald trump
we'll be releasing more of the details
today but i'm proud to report
each side will have ample time to make
arguments
if the managers decide they want
witnesses
there'll be a vote on that that's what
they requested they weren't sure they
wanted witnesses they wanted to preserve
the option
that's just what we do
and the trial will accommodate a request
from one of the trump council not to
have it on the jewish sabbath
but it will resume on sunday afternoon
after the jewish sabbath is over
over most importantly first i
spoke with mr raskin this morning he's
very happy with these
this proposal and most importantly it's
going to ensure a
fair senate impeachment allowing for
truth and accountability
truth and accountability are essential
some people say
oh let this go away oh no when something
as
horrible as dastardly that happened on
january 6th occurs you cannot sweep it
under the rug
you must have all the truth come out and
then the accountability once the truth
comes out
that's what we aim to do at this trial
okay
great okay thank you everybody yes
on the subject of bipartisanship does
this do the democrats intend to push
through the stimulus
without bipartisan support our job is to
get
a big bold plan done period
we'd welcome bipartisan support and in
fact there is bipartisan support in the
very real sense
that over 50 percent of republicans are
for this bill in all its parts
if our republican congressmen and our
republican senators
don't want to go along the needs of the
people supersede that
there are so many needs in in so many
different ways get the schools open
safely help the unemployed help the
small businesses
help the non-profits make sure that
people get
checks all of these things are so
important that we
hope we can go forward with our
republican colleagues but if we can't
we are obligated our obligation to the
nation
requires us to move forward do you want
to say anything on that
yeah i think um
you know i think the senator's spot on
here which is that
we welcome bipartisan support and there
is bipartisan
support for this bill among everyday uh
working people
including half of republicans now the
choice is in the republican conference
if they want to actually
reflect that support among actual
republicans throughout the country but
our number one priority is to help
people
our number one priority is to get people
the help that they need
to get them stimulus checks to get them
expanded access to health care
to protect their housing that's our
number one priority
and we don't want to let anything get in
our way
of our number one priority and so we
welcome that bipartisan support
we enjoy that bipartisan support among
everyday regular people in this country
and we're going to do what they have
sent us to washington to do
thank you everybody i think we'll call
it a day senator
question about what do you need dave
you